when zarathustra was 30 years old he
left his home and the lake of his home
and went into the mountains there he
enjoyed his spirit and solitude and for
10 years did not wary of it but at last
his heart changed and
rising one morning with a dawn he stood
before the sun and spoke to it thus you
great star what would your happiness be
if you had not those for whom you sign
that's how the great friedrich nietzsche
introduces us to what he called his
greatest gift to humanity the spokes
arathustra a book for all and none
nietzsche's writing style is unique he
wants to make it clear from the very
first sentences that his style is poetic
deeply philosophical adroitly rebellious
borderline ecstatic and quite often
polemic you need to know that once you
decide to read nietzsche you will have
to let go of your preconceived notions
about proper writing and embark on a
meaningful journey that will attempt to
revamp the totality of your intellectual
makeup
i'm personally in love with nietzsche he
seduces me fascinates me invigorates me
shakes up my whole world
he's really not your average philosopher
as professors kathleen higgins and
robert solomon write in the 2005
translation of the book philosophers
tend to be tediously literal but
nietzsche was a flamboyant rhetorician
who rarely shied away from even the most
outrageous overstatements and
accusations as a consequence he seems to
invite all sorts of wild interpretations
that go far beyond what he could have
literally intended nevertheless it is
evident that he was willing to be
misunderstood if that was the price of
attracting our attention and he really
did a great job of attracting our
attention the spokes arathustra is a
book for all and none as he says adding
to the symbolic and oftentimes ambiguous
nature of his statements zarathustra is
a prophet and as every prophet he
addresses everyone risking to be
understood by no one through this
controversial figure nietzsche endeavors
to immerse us in the ideas that
constitute the bedrock of his belief
system historically zarathustra is known
as zoroaster as it is stated in the
introduction of the book he was a
persian who founded his own religion
zoroastrianism in turn had a profound
influence on both judaism and
christianity central to the teachings of
the historical zarathustra was the idea
that the world is a stage on which
cosmic moral forces the power of good
and the powers of evil fight it out for
dominance over humanity this conflict
between good and evil
is central to both judaism and
christianity and
given nietzsche's rejection of this
dichotomy it is highly significant as
well as ironic that nietzsche
chose the supposed originator of that
distinction as his central character and
ostensibly as his spokesman the book has
four parts each part attempts to address
a different philosophical theme
zarathustra wanders among peculiar
characters faces weird events and tries
to communicate his philosophy through
his experience we open ourselves to a
world of unparalleled symbolic
expression to extract out philosophical
truths that we probably never even
thought of this is a world that only
nietzsche can create
when zarathustra arrived at the nearest
town at the edge of the forest he found
many people assembled in the marketplace
for it had been announced that a
tightrope walker would give a
performance and zarathustra spoke thus
to the people i teach you the ubermensch
man is something that shall be overcome
what have you done to overcome him all
beings so far have created something
beyond themselves
and you want to be the ebb of that great
tide and would rather go back to the
beast than overcome a man what is the
ape to man a stock or a painful
embarrassment and just the same shall
man be to the ubermensch a laughingstock
or a painful embarrassment this is the
first time nietzsche touches upon one of
his most popular themes that of the yuba
mensch ubermensch translates roughly to
above human or superman in english it is
a word nietzsche uses to illustrate his
idea of how man can transcend his
current state the uber mention is an
ideal it is an archetype that we can
look up to in order to navigate
ourselves better in the moral and social
landscape the best portrayal of the
ubermensch in the spokes arathustra can
be found in the following monologue
man is a rope stretched between the
animal and the ubermensch a rope over an
abyss
a dangerous crossing a dangerous on the
way a dangerous looking back a dangerous
trembling and standing still what is
great in man is that he is a bridge and
not a purpose that which is lovable in
man is that he is a transition and a
downfall i love those who don't know how
to live except when they perish for they
are those who cross over to the other
side i love the great despisers for they
are the great worshipers and arrows of
yearning for the other side i love those
who don't first look behind the stars
for a reason to perish and to be a
victim but those who sacrifice
themselves to the earth so that the
earth may one day belong to the
ubermensch i love him who lives to gain
knowledge and wishes to gain knowledge
so that the ubermans can live one day
and so he wishes his downfall the
monologue goes on in the same rhetorical
pattern there is so much to unpack here
and that's the beauty of reading
nietzsche
almost every sentence and every
paragraph hides so much meaning niches
is the current state of man as a
transition he understands the flawed
nature of modern humans and considers
the ubermensch as something that we need
to aspire towards he doesn't really
describe
the ubermensch
precisely but he provides hints he talks
about sacrifice transition process
knowledge virtue humility and downfall
he understands that if we don't
sacrifice ourselves to the extent that
we pursue our downfall and perishing
there will never be an ubermensch he
obviously talks in metaphorical terms
but he wants to make noise in order to
be heard we need to sacrifice all the
things that are holding us back and
limit our potential things that we
preserve because of fear and ignorance
we do so because we dwell in a place of
hypnosis and homeostasis only someone
who makes noise can wake us up from this
state
in the prologue of the book zarathustra
encounters a saint in the forest they
have a very intimate discussion and at
some point after zarathustra reveals
that he wants to help mankind with his
teachings they have the following
exchange do not go to men but stay in
the forest
go rather even to the animals why not be
like me a bear among bears a bird among
birds and what is the saint doing in the
forest asked zarathustra i make songs
and i sing them and in making hymns i
laugh and weep and hum thus i praise god
when zarathustra was alone he spoke thus
to his heart could it then be possible
this old saint in his forest has not yet
heard of it that god is dead
the famous phrase god is dead appeared
for the first time in gay science
however one shouldn't translate his
thesis as
anti-theological he understands the
value and purpose of religion but at the
same time he wants us to rethink our
attitude towards morality which until
that point is strongly interweaved with
religion towards the end of the 19th
century and throughout the 20th century
we see how the distancing of people from
religion has also led to a
disintegration of morality nietzsche
predicted that and wanted to warn people
and help them view morality as a
personal responsibility but he
understands that the idea of god is a
human production that managed to
synthesize societies for centuries if we
possess the thinking capacity to create
such a story that can keep society
together for so long
surely we have the resources to come up
with an alternative framework for
morality nietzsche is also quite vocal
against the idea of guilt and sin we are
trapped in this metaphysical idea of
guilt and sin originating from religious
doctrines and this is holding us back it
is holding us back from embracing reason
from thinking critically and from taking
more risks in life in order to actualize
the idea of the ubermensch by killing
god we don't become immoral but we
emancipate ourselves from metaphysical
ideas about sin and guilt finally as it
is stated in the introduction of the
book nietzsche also denounces the
otherworldly outlook of christianity its
emphasis on a better life beyond this
one zarathustra's philosophy summarized
in a single phrase
is a celebration of what is this worldly
it is a yes saying to life this life for
zarathustra like nietzsche thinks that
there is no other
you call it will to truth you wisest man
that which impels you and fills you with
lust
a will to the thinkability of all being
thus i call your will you would make all
being thinkable for you doubt with a
healthy mistrust
whether it is already thinkable but it
shall yield and bend to you so wills
your will it shall become smooth and
serve the spirit as its mirror and
reflection that is your entire will your
wisest man as a will to power and that
is even when you speak of good and evil
and of valuations nietzsche was a big
fan of schopenhauer but he also opposed
some of his views schopenhauer has
famously spoken of a will to live the
will as sopenhauer understands it is the
expression of the desire of all nature
to pursue and propagate life without
will there can be no life but also this
will for self-preservation creates a
competitive and dynamic landscape
through which most of mankind's misery
and suffering is manifested nietzsche's
opposing arguments to the will to live
was the will to power the will to power
is often misunderstood as people tend to
to associate it with dominance
aggression and the desire to enforce
one's will upon others nichiri viewed
power as energy he was obsessed with the
idea of movement self-expression
dynamism he viewed the world as an
eternally evolving and moving mechanism
and thus movement and power were
essential elements of this mechanism the
will to personal power is about the
desire to become oneself it is the
driving force behind any attempt for
self-actualization the will to power is
closely related to the idea of the
ubermensch but also to the idea of the
eternal recurrence as this will be
discussed shortly without the driving
force to push us towards our goals and
in nichian terms the ultimate goal is
the ubermensch we will never reach those
goals at the same time our goals are
never static they are dynamic they
change and oftentimes they repeat
themselves they occur eternally and are
just part of the absurdity of existence
the will to power can help us power
through this absurdity
sing and bubble over ozarathustra heal
your soul with new songs that you may
bear your great destiny which has not
yet been anyone's destiny for your
animals know it well o zarathustra who
you are and must become behold you are
the teacher of the eternal return that
is now your destiny that you must be the
first to teach this teaching how could
this great destiny not be your greatest
danger and sickness behold we know what
you teach that all things eternally
return and we ourselves with them and
that we have already existed an infinite
number of times and all things with us
the idea of eternal recurrence is quite
prevalent in nietzsche's latest works he
experiments with the possibility of time
as circular and that most instances in
our lives occur in a recurring fashion
certain experiences do indeed constitute
recurring themes in our lives human
relationships have similarities and we
can identify specific patterns of
behavior across most human interactions
i'm not sure if nietzsche was referring
to that or if he had something else in
mind in one of his unpublished notes he
writes the question which you will have
to answer before every deed that you do
is this such a deed i am prepared to
perform an incalculable number of times
heidegger believes that nietzsche
presents the concept of eternal
recurrence as a hypothetical as it is
stated in wikipedia the significant
point is the burden imposed by the
question of eternal recurrence
regardless of whether or not such a
thing could possibly be true again
probably nietzsche alludes to the idea
of
self-responsibility and that we need to
be careful when we pick our fights there
is also a connection between eternal
recurrence and free will if there is a
mechanism that generates an eternal
recurrence of things we are quite
certainly not in charge of this
mechanism free will isn't free in that
case and a lot of our actions are
predetermined there is however some
freedom in that space the primal freedom
that he thinks we have is in what way we
deal with internal drives and the
obstacles that come our way he knows
that some things are not within our
control but the ones that are need to be
pursued through the will to power the
will to personal power and
self-ownership regardless of how
strenuous and difficult and full of
failures this life might be
we need to power through it and at some
point decide to love our fate a more
fatty as he writes you hire men it longs
for you this joy the irrepressible
blissful for your woe your failures all
eternal joy longs for failures for all
joy wants itself therefore it also wants
agony oh happiness oh pain
o break heart you hire men learn it well
that all joy wants eternity joy wants
the eternity of all things it wants deep
deep eternity
hey guys hope you enjoyed today's video
if you did make sure to like subscribe
turn on notifications and comment below
something cool please so that more
people can discover it
if you want to watch more videos from my
channel check out this one and this one
take care see you soon adrian out